today i want to talk about this
phenomenon that i have been seeing
around me that deserves more attention
it's this phenomenon of being optimal on
paper and therefore being broken in
reality um and it's kind of a general
story we have this idea that we have
like an analytics translator it's kind
of a role within the company and then
the very common question is something
like well we have an actual problem we
will turn that into an analytical
problem we add a little bit of data into
the mix
maybe we do some stuff with algorithms
right and then we have this analytical
problem and we can say we have a 10
boost yay we're doing the good thing
we're solving an issue here
but what often gets forgotten is that
you still did the translation in this
direction which means that at some point
you're also going to have to make a
translation back into the other
direction and you could wonder if that
10 boost in your analytical domain
actually translates back because there's
bound to be some form of translation app
uh sort of error happening here and
i fear that it's getting a little bit
too easy to look at that 10 boost and go
oh i'm doing the good thing while
ignoring all the translation errors that
are happening at the same time
and
it's the way i would like to describe
that is something can be optimal on
paper and broken in reality and i think
the more attention that you pay to it
the more that you're going to see it and
this is especially true in the domain of
model benchmarking so i would like to do
now as a first demo is just show you a
benchmark and we'll see what goes wrong
that's that's going to be the idea so
i've got this jupyter notebook and also
just for context i work at this company
called raza
we are building open source software to
build virtual assistants and chat bots
so lots of nlp that's kind of my domain
so i figured you know what might be a
common task well maybe we would like to
evaluate which embeddings are good for
virtual assistants
um so for those of you a little bit less
familiar don't worry too much about it
embedding is basically a thing where
text goes in and some array of numbers
comes out and hopefully that array of
numbers is somehow a proxy for the
meaning of the text that came in it
doesn't actually work like that but good
enough just we have an array of numbers
and i was kind of curious well let's
take text that represents an intent
so
buy me a pizza okay then the intent is
you want to purchase something what's
the time okay then i want to know what
time it is and i have this data set with
150 intents each intent has 150 examples
in it and i figured let's try out a
couple of pipelines uh one thing i uh
so the basic pipeline is text goes in
every word is getting indexed and every
word is then a feature in the pipeline
so for every word we're going to
calculate the weight
to figure out uh
how much that's going to influence the
label
then we also have the same thing but for
sub words
we have yet um and then we have the
thing where we do the checking with the
embeddings we have one embedding that
comes from uh
meta facebook uh called fast text they
trained a system and there's another
thing based on sort of a more bird kind
of model uh called the universal
sentence encoder and that is from uh
google
again the whole point of this exercise
is that we're hopefully gonna learn
something that's general about chatbots
because it will be kind of nice if we
could measure if there's a difference
between fast text and universal sentence
encoder okay uh so this is the pipeline
right the only thing i'll be changing to
this pipeline is just this one embedding
i'm going to flip out the fast text i'm
going to flip out the universal sentence
encoder okay if this was like a
benchmark that you might see an academic
paper then probably the end result is
something like this you'll see a table
right and i'll zoom in just a little bit
to make it a bit bigger but but you
might see a table like this like the
fast text has an accuracy of uh not 91
and the other one's not 92. all right
universal sentence encoder that's better
now if this is a good article something
is a little bit more focused towards
like industry and practice i would argue
you would also list the prediction time
and one of the things that you would see
here is that the universal sentence
encoder is like a factor more than 10
slower just to compute basically
it's okay so far so good but you can
still you know call it a win because oh
man we have a higher number
and this is common right you typically
we all have we've all seen these
situations where one model has a higher
number than the other one but let's now
dive into all the things that may go
wrong here because i think that there's
a bit of a force in the background the
first one is that we are not asking how
many data points we're actually basing
this number on
because if we now pretend that this is
an a b test right and we do the the beta
distribution trick i could say well
there's 4 000 examples
in my test set so there's also like a
confidence interval around this number
right
i should probably make that plot
so
here's the beta distribution trick and
here's the plot that you might get fast
text has a number but it has a certainty
bounce around it universal sense encoder
same thing also has a certain bounds
around it and if you look at it this way
instead of just looking at that one
number you do kind of go gee there's a
bit of overlap between those two
distributions right it's not that clear
anymore that one number is actually
larger than the other one and if you
were to really formalize this into like
a hypothesis test you could kind of say
well you know it's
it's the number here is not eight five
usually people like not nine five
instead so am i really that convinced
that this one model is better
maybe not
the thing that i find a bit interesting
and tricky about this is i think it's
not a common industry practice to do
this
a lot of people really like to look at
the one number but i would hopefully
hopefully you will agree that yeah
there's also this uncertainty bound
around it and if i have a way simpler
model that's very light this can be a
great argument
to your colleagues to say well we can
still use the light model because the
confidence bounds don't guarantee that
the other models actually weigh better
this can be a great way to keep your
systems light in practice i would love
to see it more but this is not even the
worst thing that happened in our
benchmark
because you see
if i just have a look at this pipeline
again if i'm trying to say well i'm
comparing two approaches the one thing
that i haven't been doing is just
comparing it with the most simple thing
out there and the most simple thing out
there would just be well let's just do
no embeddings whatsoever let's just look
at the words and the sub words index all
of those get away for them and
that should be the simplest thing right
like maybe that should also be included
in this benchmark because otherwise i'm
just comparing neural networks with each
other instead of just considering the
really simple thing
now if i want to show you the effect of
this i also have to do something else i
think because you can also wonder
the quality of this model that i'm
measuring the accuracy number is that a
function of the embedding
or is that a function of the data that's
going in
because i could also argue here the more
data that i give this thing the better
the model right and it might also be the
case that and certain embeddings are
better in low data scenarios and other
embeddings are better in high data
scenarios
and this little table is not showing me
that part of the story
so what i'm now going to do is just give
you a really cool use case for the
altera visualization library because
what i've done let's zoom out just a
little bit
is i've uh re-ran the entire benchmark
but now i've taken a subsample at every
time so first i'm training with 500
examples then a thousand and then two
thousand then three thousand et cetera
and you see the accuracy uh for the test
that listed over here
now the cool thing about this altera
library is that you can zoom in because
if we are going to spot the difference
between the fast text model and the
count vectors we are going to have to
zoom in quite a bit
um
yeah
like really really zooming in here right
there's barely a difference between fast
text and just doing count factors i i am
inclined to say we might have one
example more
just by staring at this right
but that's not even the biggest part of
the story um one part of the story here
is like oh yeah like really universal
sentencing code is doing a little bit
better than just the basic account
figures not that much but another part
of the story is you notice how much
better we're getting just by adding more
data
another really cool feature about like
being able to zoom in here
is that you can look at this and you can
kind of go you know what
the slope here ain't done yet
there's still this delta y delta x
happening here so if i'm going to draw
any conclusion at this point yeah i can
spend a lot of effort maybe finding an
even more fancier model than a universal
sentence encoder and get me wrong like
don't get me wrong universal sensing
code is amazing there's a lot of stuff
to like about that thing but for this
problem
it is a distraction i should be getting
more data that's the only normal
conclusion you can get when you look at
this chart and if i were to reflect now
and say well that's not what this table
says
then for a benchmark it's too easy to be
optimal on paper but broken in reality
and i see a lot of people nodding now so
that's nice confirmation but it's not
even the most broken thing about this
benchmark
because we've not talked about the data
yet
so let's have a look at the data set
that we're actually doing here
i have a sub sample here of the data set
so you can get a bit of an example right
so the text will you turn the tv on okay
that's a label for smart home this is
smart home command right
call an uber for two people to go to
fourth street all right uber that's an
intent there's a thank you there's a
sync device there's a credit card limit
there's how busy are you there's
translate
i don't know of a single virtual
assistant
in production at let's say a bank
that also allows you to order an uber or
to like make it i think you're also able
to like throw a dice or something like
this so we are talking about this data
set that has like 150 intents
but those are intense from like all
sorts of different virtual assistants
and if they're all sorts of different
virtual assistants odds are that all
those intents are mutually exclusive
so if i were an actual bank making an
actual virtual assistant let's say
uh questions about a debit card and
christensen about a credit a debit card
and credit card are really similar but
that's much harder than whatever we're
doing here
so if i'm going to say anything general
about the universal sense encoder is
great for chat bots then i also have to
recognize that whatever benchmark data
set i have here it doesn't match reality
it doesn't match whatever problem that i
necessarily have
and this is true not just for this one
benchmark but maybe for pretty much
every pre-trained model out there
right
and this is kind of an issue it's
getting really easy to be optimal on
paper and to convince ourselves that
we're really doing something that's
clever while we're really being sort of
separating ourselves from reality and
this is i think a reason for concern
so i like to think this is a very
general problem and what i'm about to do
is i'm about to draw a venn diagram
mainly because it helps to shape the
problem also for non-technical
stakeholders
because the way i look at it and this is
something i've definitely learned while
working at raza is if you're looking at
a data science problem there's kind of
these two circles and you're really
hoping that they will overlap because on
one end that you do have the stuff that
you optimize you have your models you
have your metrics there is this there's
definitely a reason why we like doing
analytical things because it gives us a
path towards optimization but a big part
of the danger here is that it doesn't
necessarily overlap with stuff that our
users care about
so if i'm helping out a team or a
community member building a virtual
assistant people are usually surprised
to learn that i'm really not that you
know i'm i know my algorithms but i
barely talk about algorithms when i'm
helping people usually i'm explaining
this to them the real thing the real
trouble and the real hard part is
ensuring that this overlap is actually
quite big
and there's this guy on twitter that i
follow he has he basically has the best
quote on this a large part of this is
that
maybe the biggest impediment to
enterprises getting value from ai today
is that we've convinced the world that
tweaking hyper parameters is prestigious
high value work and that curating a high
quality data set is tedious grunt work
to be outsourced minimized or automated
i i genuinely feel this vibe follow him
on twitter by the way he's also my boss
um
but but i do but i really love this
tweet because it really does summarize
what i think is a huge problem in
enterprise today i hear stories from
consultants that say i would love to
have a look at my labels
but the
person paying my check thinks i'm too
expensive to actually look at the data
so we're outsourcing that to some person
in a different part of the world which
feels really weird
and that
kind of brings me to the second demo
that i want to show you
so
a lot of nlp revolves around sentiment
for some weird reason whenever people go
oh what's the what's the use case for
nlp people always kind of go ah
sentiments binary classification and i
get that
um but i figured we should maybe do it
properly and i came across this data set
from google
the data set is called the go emotions
data set um basically what they did is
they scraped reddit um
and they basically have text like this
like oh my god yep that's the final
answer thank you so much there's a label
gratitude and there's a label approval
what's likable about this is that
instead of saying it's a sentiment
between zero and one and we're gonna
reduce the dimensionality of human
cultural sentiment into a single axis
we're just gonna say no no no it's more
complex we're gonna have a label for
every single emotion so confusion
remorse surprise amusement
disappointment we're gonna basically
have a classification problem it's a lot
like tagging
so it's not zero or one it's lots of
zeros and lots of ones one for each
emotion here
um and i would like to stress like this
is a data set that not only google put
out there this is a data set and also
like stanford and amazon alexa like
multiple worked on this but it's also
one that they wrote a paper about
so there's effort being taken here that
this is a good data set and we can read
a little bit about it um we took an
effort that multiple people labeled a
single row but i will say google is sort
of putting this out there which is
giving me the impression huh this is a
data set that i can go ahead and use
this is something i can train models on
this is probably something that's nice
and curated useful because emotion
detection has a use case i suppose
then again
there is this other project called
labelers.com i recommend you go here
daily
what this project is all about and
generally the the authors really did a
cool thing here they basically said look
there might be mislabeled instances in
imagenet
there might be mislabeled images in
quickdraw or the amazon sentiment data
set
and how like if people are bragging
about how state-of-the-art your model is
they're saying like hey i've plus two
percent on my test set but the test set
has three percent label errors
that'd be bad right
okay so let's just look at a few
examples um according to imagenet this
is a bathtub
and this is a red panda
and i can scroll for a while
right
and imagenet is a culprit uh there's a
paper attached to this project that's a
pretty it's a good read
there's an open source project called
clean lab that's associated with this
work as well
what's really interesting is that they
also give estimates of how bad the label
errors might be per data set um the
authors estimate that quick draw has a
10 label error
10.
uh amazon supposedly has around two
right that's also pretty bad
so then you start wondering can i find
bad labels in the google emotions they
decide
let's try some stuff right so this i've
pre-made this but i'm just going to try
to so imagine that i was doing this
exercise at home and i was just kind of
curious like hey we have this label
errors.com argument
maybe that's seeping in some data sets
that i might be using so it would be
good to maybe just have a look like we
should care about this stuff right like
if i'm responsible for the output of my
algorithm boy am i also responsible for
the stuff going in right
okay so there's a few things in this
data set but i'm gonna um because the
data is from reddit i'm only gonna zoom
in on the excitement uh label of
interest uh like be careful with reddit
data there's really a lot of garbage
text on there
but we have a couple of examples here
right so um
i have text here that's uh you know
labeled excitement01 but there is some
other stuff in here as well
because i also have a radar id this is
the person who gave the label supposedly
there's an identifier for that that's in
this data set and the raider is also
able to give it a very uh sort of state
that the example is really unclear
which is fair right emotion detection is
by no means like easy to label so i
think this is actually a really good
practice and i commend the authors uh
that they've done this but just from the
sample right
like i'm sure there are people who
really enjoy being parents though those
people aren't us and aren't
most parents i'm not sure if that's
excitement
this is from sampling right
i'm about to show you tricks that are
better than sampling but this already
demonstrated just sampling a couple of
rows is already a good idea
i do agree with this though
okay so uh what i do is i first say it
might help to have a machine learning
model around
the goal of this machine learning model
is to help guide me it's kind of like a
ah
chatbot kind of not really but in a way
it's trying to it's gonna help me try to
figure out which labels might be bad and
the reasoning here is if i'm going to be
fitting a model on a train set and then
using it on the train set it will be
kind of weird
if it wasn't able to predict the label
correctly right
especially if it's like on a spectrum of
high bias high variance models count
vector holistic regression is really
high bias so like if the high bias model
doesn't work on the train sets
something's up right that's kind of the
idea
but it's also logistic regression in the
sense that if you have the separating
plane you can also suggest that maybe
all the points that are really close to
that boundary
those are my
might be the points where there's a lot
of doubt where the model is really
unsure what the label should be
so maybe we can also think about machine
learning models not necessarily as
models to predict something but more as
models that will help us label
and maybe there's also this avenue of
work that we can consider where maybe if
we have different models with different
qualities they will all have a different
lens that allows us to look at data
differently
so let's just see what happens when we
do this
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to use the model uncertainty trick
if the predict probe value is like close
to 0.5 it's binary then i'm going to
suggest like okay we should just have a
look
so i have my logistic regression i do my
fit proba and here's some of the
examples that i get
that's adorable as f it's not excitement
so this one i think okay uh
there might be a cultural difference
this is a this is trifol
this could go either way i think
personally
but then i see oh my god those tiny
shoes desire to boop snoot intensifies
and and you know like so it is slag
right the language is not necessarily
straightforward
someone who was labeling this might have
had a different culture we see that it
was a very unclear example
but
this i relate to this so much almost too
much
i mean there are also examples you're
like if there's a pattern yes that's not
excitement right so it's this is a proxy
this is not necessarily a guarantee or
anything
but uh hmm okay
uh
what happens if we do some other tricks
um this is a trick i like to call short
on confidence the idea is that there is
a correct label according to the data
set and if my model
has like almost
zero confidence that that's correct
that's bad right so i'm going to sort
based on that so correct class if that
has a really low score i want to see
those examples first
and the first example when i do this is
i'm inexplicably excited by name i get
so excited by how we curl passes this is
a very clear example and it's not about
excitement the world excited is in the
sentence twice
and i'm like i'm cherry picking a little
bit here but then the second sentence is
oh my god this is so amazing keep up the
awesome work and have a fantastic new
year and like these are two people
apparently who labeled it this way
uh and you know there's a bunch oh my
god yes such an amazing combo i mean
that could be excitement this is kind of
weird
now the cool thing that i will show you
as a demo which i think is really
interesting is right now i'm using the
count factorizer model again high bias
what i can also do is use an embedding
model
embeddings that are trained on wikipedia
use no count vectors whatsoever and just
sort of say well what does that produce
do i get different examples
and the answer is yeah you do like you
really really do
if you do that
i'm using biparem bettings now you get
these examples
now this is word embeddings right so
these word embeddings have to be pulled
together uh which loses a little bit of
information so what is interesting to
observe is that we tend to get the
examples that are much shorter we get
not really long sentences more like
direct comments but come on wow three
exclamation points that's not excitement
this is this is troubling right this is
this is this is no bueno
now the clean labels era data set that i
just showed you earlier um so the label
errors i should say the author of that
also wrote this library called clean lab
it contains a mathematically sensible
heuristic to also find bad labels
which you can which i recommend people
it's a it's a cool library it works and
what you can also do is just run that
heuristic it's a single function call
you feed it your probes you feel it's
your labels and then it will also sort
of come up with a list of stuff that
just deserves double checking
now i do want to add a little bit of
nuance because
i'll
apologize for the quick scrolling but
you can also measure that different
raters had like a different uh you know
feeling about this one example so i'm
inexplicably excited by name uh get so
excited how you cope that one example i
mean there were two different raiders
who thought about it differently so in a
way you could argue hey the data set
also contains a little bit of doubt here
but how am i going to trust a model
that's sort of trained on this
right
and also just looking at everyone in the
room
i think it's it's easy for me to say
here because text is relatively easy to
label
but i don't think it's a common industry
practice to do this exercise
but for computer vision models and for
text models those are two really cool
examples where you can assign doubt to
your labels and you can actually check
hey am i even training on the right
thing
because if i'm talking about being
optimal and paper and broken in reality
this is like villain number uno right if
we have bad labels in our data set and
we're unaware of it we are going to
we're going to report super optimistic
numbers disappoint a whole lot of people
if this ever gets to production
[Music]
and you know
there's a reason why i do kind of want
to talk about this
this is a screenshot from
a model that's hosted on hugging face
now i should stress hugging face is
doing a lot of cool stuff uh non-english
they're doing a really you know cool
work and i think it's nice that they
have sort of a way for anyone to upload
a model
however when you look at the model card
it says there's two things that people
will read one of them is the example
that you can run is i love auto llp
and the other one is that it has a
pretty high accuracy score on the imdb
sentiment classification data set
which is probably going to make you
think like ah that's pretty useful i
might just go ahead and use that as a
sentiment model or maybe fine-tune on it
and i cannot blame you if you do because
it's giving you reasons to put
confidence in the model
but i hope we also agree i cannot
guarantee you that there will be no
label errors on the data set that this
thing was trained on
in fact you can also wonder like with
the example before
maybe imdb text differs from what people
are doing in your virtual assistant
maybe it's just a completely different
set of examples
and how can i guarantee that even if you
fine-tune you're not overfitting on
something else that's been pre-trained
you can also find the google emotions
data set on this platform and you can
have this little
ui element to see all the different
models that people have trained on it
i doubt
unfortunately that they have done this
exercise of finding bad labels i think
if you want to make this data set
properly clean it's going to be a huge
effort actually
um and i think we should care um again
if i make this drawing off we have an
actual problem that gets turned into an
analytical problem and we're going to
translate that back and if i then see
this development of it's going to be
easier and easier which is also kind of
a good thing that people can just
fine-tune their models or whatever big
data sets they can find
it's going to be really hard for me to
understand what's actually in the model
right
and
this is what i you know if i have to
sort of tell people what is raza really
working on like yeah we're doing
research on algorithms we want to have
our stuff be super efficient but a very
large chunk of the research is actually
going into how do we give tools to
people for data quality um so
things like hey you have an intent class
that you're using inside of your virtual
assistant it only has six examples
please add more or hey there's a couple
of examples between these two intents uh
seems to be causing a lot of confusion
could you please just verify and check
um i could make the biggest investments
that i want into more tensorflow and
like faster gpus and stuff but it's
gonna be meaningless unless this thing
is sorted um and that also is kind of
why i got hired like they hired me with
like a pretty simple mission i am here
to explain this sort of things to people
uh on youtube i host an educational
channel where i explain how our
algorithms work
our most recent tensorflow algorithm
only looks for
conversations where something unexpected
happened as in these are algorithms that
we'll try to help you label
that's where most of our research really
is going and also all of our attention
because if usually if there's a failure
it's there
we also highly recommend everyone to
just
even if you're the senior data scientist
you have to look at the logs what people
sort of say to your virtual assistant
it's basically because of this
so um what does that mean for the rest
of us like my background is nlp i can
imagine that's not everyone's use case
here but i do think that there are some
general lessons that apply beyond just
my own domain
i think that in general we really should
consider the effect of the training size
more before we run a grid search grid
search will typically give you this one
number
but that one number is not going to tell
you like the number of examples and that
sort of thing it's a huge dimensionality
reduction of reality i also think that
it might be good to consider that one
metric might not reflect the complexity
of reality at all it's just a single
number you're going to optimize for one
single number but in reality you're
typically interested in like five things
also i think it's good to consider that
pre-trained models might not reflect
your problem especially because they
might be trained on wrong labels i also
would like everyone to maybe consider
doing this finding bad labels exercise
in their own data set
moreover though i would like to consider
that everything i've discussed in this
talk might just be the tip of the
iceberg i've not talked about fairness
and bias issues that's also a huge topic
that we're gonna have to talk about
right
so
the common thing in all of this though
is that i think it's one thing to have a
broken system but it's even worse if
you're blind to it and that's the whole
point that i'm trying to make here i
fear that
it's getting really easy to download a
pre-trained model with a very high
number that that's going to give you
false confidence and that false
confidence might just be the reason that
you're not putting enough doubt in your
own system and that i think is a very
legitimate concern that more people
should think about
speaking of which
um i dabble in open source projects now
and again and i started looking at this
label error stuff and i just started to
think well if if we're all going to be
better looking for bad labels it would
help if we had like some great tools
that are supposed to do this sort of
thing right
so
as of yesterday you can pip install
doubt lab it is a suite of tools where
the whole point is that it's easy for
you to declare a couple of reasons why
you might want to assign doubts to a row
of data the whole point is that you
might have a couple of different models
some of them might be text-based for now
i'm mainly targeting the cycle learn
ecosystem but the whole point is that
you can maybe come up with 10 reasons
why something might be off could be an
outlier let's say right
um and then we are just gonna handle the
sorting such that after a couple of
minutes you just have a list of examples
that deserve to be checked
first
the api is relatively simple you just
assign a doubt and sample you can make
keyword arguments or a dictionary where
you just give a name to a reason
you can have a reason for proba that's
like the low confidence close to 0.5
give it a machine learning model you can
have more than one of these you can have
multiple models all that stuff works
you could also say if there's a wrong
prediction there's also a reason and i
can give you either the indices of all
the rows as you double check or a data
frame of predicates that's sorted which
will also tell you all the reasons uh
why
i hope this is super exciting that's a
qr code so if you want to check out the
github repo you can totally do that
this is stuff that i'm working for on
behalf of raza as well
my employer would love to tell you that
we're hiring but moreover ask me
anything i'd love to hear i would love
to get more feedback on this i am going
to work on this this year so please
check this out
thanks for listening
[Applause]
who wants to catch the cube
got it
thanks for your talk
awesome that you also have a library
available
i think it was very exciting and i have
a question about the excitement uh
example so the thing i'm wondering is
you showed some of the labels in the
beginning
and then you showed basically all the
misclassified
excitement examples i wonder
what labels did they get classified as
maybe there's like something like
which labels did they could you repeat
the question
so the question is what labels did they
get excited maybe they're like joy or
happy or something that's very close to
excitement um
so the the paper actually lists that
there is a bit of correlation so uh
there's like uh emotions that are a
little bit more on the positive side of
the spectrum so to say and they tend to
correlate a bit so joy and excitement
are more common than excitement and
anger for example yes so that and that
all can also be used to find bad labels
of course um
i could so the thing is i would love to
show you some examples but this is
reddit data so i prefer to do that when
the camera is off
now because it's reddit there really is
some horrible stuff in here that i'm not
comfortable uh putting on youtube no no
okay so please come to me afterwards
i'll gladly show you some details if you
like okay but i guess
also part of the answer is like every
emotion can be zero or one and you can
have multiple also yeah it's tagging
it's not classification it's tagging
yeah okay yeah okay
one thing i should also emphasize here
um that's actually good to mention
sentiment is a really weird use case
when you think about it right because
it's so opinionated and so determined by
culture
and also um i think sarcasm detection is
an unsolved problem
so how on earth can sentiment ever be
solved right if we cannot detect sarcasm
we don't we cannot detect emotion if we
cannot detect emotion we cannot do
sentiment
it's an incredibly hard problem that's
also a lesson i've learned from doing
this
thanks
all the way in the back
whoa
[Applause]
thanks uh it was a fantastic talk and i
can relate to that so much
yeah so i
i wonder you you presented the the the
reaper right right uh doubt lab right
i mean it's it's live since yesterday so
yeah it's okay it's it is fresh of the
press and that's it i was wondering if
you think it's something that cannot be
already
operationalized or it's still kind of in
the research phase in the sense
is that much is it mature enough kind of
the field of um yeah
well okay so uh
i made this it's live since yesterday
like uh please don't bet your company on
it right
yeah sure single dude here um having
said that um
this is not meant to be run live this is
meant to be run on your offline data set
yeah so and and to be honest i think
it's better to
use this as a reason to actually look at
your data yeah and to maybe help you
sort what to look at first everything
from there is something the library
won't solve for you that's something you
have to do because it depends on your
problem which you will understand better
than this you know for loop ever will
yeah so maybe let me rephrase it uh
let's say i do this of course i do it on
my on my data i want to understand a bit
and
so do you think that kind of you can
cover already a large
number of use cases with these or is
there something that you think you can
add in the future let's say one to two
years or is there something that the
machine learning community still has to
develop in order to get more
understanding um so there there is some
fairness and so you though you are right
that i do think there's a weakness in
this approach namely what could happen
is that i'm going to present you with
examples to look at and then people are
gonna go i check those
done
that's dangerous right because uh these
models will have blind spots too uh
you're gonna train maybe badly you're
gonna train on bad labels
and then you're gonna use a model
trained on those bad labels to have less
bad labels but
it really depends on how bad the labels
were in the first place
so um
and also if you're using word embeddings
those are biased too so there's there's
all sorts of things that may or may not
work what i will definitely say is
this will be there's tools available now
that are super useful i am eagerly
asking everyone here to give me feedback
because because i that's also the cool
way about the way i can do research i
don't have to work i get to work with a
community instead of working with a
static data set so if all of you tell me
hey i've eyeballed it this works better
than that that's great now in terms of
plans for the future there's there are
two things that i do have in the back of
my mind this works really well for x and
y kinds of situations so so i could
learn maybe image classification entity
detection not so much because that's a
nested data structure and also finding
like where is the garbage bin in this
photo maybe there's two of them so
that's going to be a bit awkward with
this api i might want to make a separate
ensemble for that another thing that
i've also been thinking about is
this kind of reminds me of snorkel a
little bit you could look at this reason
and say that's kind of like a a weak
business rule we might be able to do
something clever with aggregating that
instead of just looking at overlap um
that said though
if this thing is going to tell you look
these are outliers if you check those
out i would argue that's a good idea now
how you're going to do outliers depends
on your problem but i think there's
already enough in here and there are
unit tests uh that it's worth for people
to do the exercise um but it's not it's
not done forever project uh this is
something that definitely requires a
year's worth of time i think cool yeah
thanks that's one person left i think
and i'm also here like during the break
right so don't worry uh you want to see
demos ivinson thank you we could switch
we should we should switch
final question after that uh there's
going to be a break but i'll be here uh
final question yet i mean
by checking these uh wrongly labeled
data set uh
i mean at some point do you think we
would be throwing away the culture from
the data set we're throwing away the
what sorry by checking these wrong
labels in the data set at some point do
you think we'll be throwing away the
culture
from the model
um
um
so the question is are we going to throw
away the culture from the model um
i the only the most reasonable thing i
can say on the spot here there is we you
got to be careful with culture right a
good thing to be aware of but it really
depends on your application as well
so to answer your question fully also
depends a lot on the application and if
i have more context there i might be
able to give you more pointing advice
i do agree that a lot of this nlp stuff
is really tricky because language is
cultural and
and that but that's made that makes the
whole field super complicated language
is not a bag of words
but i do think it would be good to put
more doubt in these systems and that's
what i'm trying to achieve here you
could also go overboard that i agree
with yeah
oh oh so we do have time for your
question all right
all right let's go reuben
um so whether so
this is just a toolkit that is
customizable that will allow you
hopefully more easily to find weird
things in your data set what you do with
it depends on you that's i really try i
don't try to be opinionated in terms of
what you should do with uh with when you
when you find weird examples that that
really depends on your use case as well
so that's responsibility that i would
like to pass on to the data scientist
okay
right all right